[Musique]
avec les suites justement Michel des
fausses alertes à la bombe au château de
Versailles l'un des auteurs a été jugé
ce lundi il avait averti je cite le
trône de Louis XIV va sauter à plus le
responsable de ce canular a été
interpellé grâce à son numéro de
téléphone il a reconnu les fait en garde
à vue l'individu de 37 ans souffre de
schizophrénie à un casier judiciaire
vierge au chômage et toujours chez ses
parents la motivation terroriste n'a pas
été retenue il compar assz libre devant
le tribun judiciaire de Versailles qui a
rendu son verdict une mauvaise blague
qui lui vaut 8 mois de prison avec
surcis et des dommages et intérêts non
chiffrés deux policiers de guancour on
été placé pendant plusieurs heures en
garde à vue après l'utilisation de leur
arme à feu les faits se sont produit ce
dimanche un individu a été pris en
chasse vers 15h sur la commune de
guencour la raison ce jeune homme de 19
ans avait dérobé un véhicule avant de
prendre la fuite jusqu'à Viller lebacle
c'est là que le forcenet a tenté de
forcer un barrage de policiers les deux
fonctionnaires ont alors ouvert le feu
le blessant au thorax un temp placé en
garde à vue les deux policiers ont été
remis en liberté ce lundi matin selon le
parquet de Versailles les jours du
fugitif ne sont plus en danger c'était
ce matin le ministre délégué chargé du
numérique Jean-Noël Barot était à
Montini le Bretonneux exactement
grégoryi le ministre était venu pour
soutenir un projet de formation qui vise
à renforcer l'employabilité des talents
son nom la talent académie son objectif
susciter des vocations notamment chez
les jeunes femmes sur les métiers
scientifiques et techniques pour se
faire le programme Saxe autour de trois
thèmes éduqués formés et recrutés on
écoute Sophie Duma la directrice de la
formation qui nous en dit plus au micro
de Clara de Frutos sur le programme
incubateur par exemple nous avons
aujourd'hui une communauté avec à peu
près 700 apprentis donc à qui nous
proposons des des activités diverses par
exemple des des visites de sites des des
rencontres avec des start-up parce que
ces jeunes ils sont friants de ce monde
de des start-ups donc c'était à l'école
2600 je n'avais pas précisé on termine
avec plus de légèreté pour pour ces
actualités du jour une idée de sortie en
ces vacances de la tousin tout à fait
grégoryi le 28 octobre à versaill une
Murder Pary sera organisée pour fêter
Halloween une sorte de jeu de rôle
grandeur nature dans l'ancien domaine de
Madame ellisabeth transformée pour
l'occasion une base militaire et
scientifique pour développer des super
soldats mais tout ne va pas se passer
comme prévu votre objectif est simple
résoudre l'enquête et fuir les zombies
pendant 45 minutes compter 25 € par
personne et 16 ans minimum pour vivre
cette exper
merci Michel et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une information qui vous fait
réagir dans les evel n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news